hey guys back at Roseanne's with jen
hoffman and i'm sure you guys heard this
already Saudi King Abdullah died a
couple days ago and when he died I
tweeted something that I thought was I
actually think it was that clever or
whatever but it got a couple hundred
retweets and and then people started
going crazy on me and I thought it was
kind of interesting so what I tweeted
was King Abdullah beheaded citizens
didn't let women Drive had death
sentence for gays this is what's known
as a moderate in the Middle East now
those are just facts women cannot drive
in Saudi Arabia you can get the death
penalty for being gay now there's a
question to whether they've done that in
the last year or so but you can't
economics it's on the books right and
either way pretty not a good place for
the gays and the third one beheaded
citizens I mean they behead people all
the time actually the new york times
obituary for him in the section about
his moderation they talked about how he
was beheading terrorists oh ok i got a
lot of crazy responses on this now I
wasn't condemning by any stretch all the
people of Saudi Arabia I want as a
liberals but I always says as a liberal
I stand up for liberal principles so I
want women to be equal I want gays to be
equal I don't want the headings in
streator those are pretty simple yes
that's him radically outrageous radical
things to say about someone it's not you
said I'm glad he's dead comma he be had
in citizens you had no real opinion on
that whatsoever you just kind of said
hey here's some facts about this dude
who just died and like said it yeah I'd
be one crazy yeah so I was getting a ton
of responses by the way I wasn't saying
also that we should do anything about it
I don't know what we should do is every
time we do a story on the Middle East I
always say I don't know what we should
do half the time we try to do something
only make it worse anyway so I wanted to
roll through a couple of these responses
that i got so here's this first one oh
please shut up like you're all so
perfect i thought that was yes well for
the first thing I to point out I know
grammar doesn't matter but the first
thing is they use the wrong your and I
was reading through some of these tweets
as they were coming into him the first
thing to say is we don't have to ever
get into it again regarding Twitter
response people is that they're all when
they were saying stupid stuff stupid
people like so is the wrong your it's
always among their they spell somebody
wrote shut the [ __ ] up to you and they
spelt shut wrong their [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
i don't think they meant yeah well it
will get to that what's it but the
spelling stuff i don't want to get too
hung over
that's why I wanted to start it with
that by saying before cuz it because I
know there's people that are reading
this and they're gonna write in the
comment section they're gonna bit full
and it's funny commenters to like those
fight with each other we can't even
spell in your whatever but that when you
get idiotic responses you always have to
realize the source is what I was saying
I'm not right I don't want to get into
the grammar of what everyone rotary I
don't so there might be a language
barrier because I did get a lot of
people from Saudi Arabia that's Jim
there's people from the US that were
writing you back that word spelling like
basic words like the wrong yeah that
just I just want to set the mentality
that you're dealing with when people
attack something simple you say moving
forward we never have to address it
again but so people know that we know
that that yeah yeah uh by the way I
should note now that we're talking about
spelling but I actually did make a
slight yes spelling error I wrote know
instead of known right this is what's
know as a moderate so I made a mistake
myself see I'm not better that's what
I'm thing I'm not a pic some people
somebody I just think you're gonna write
it ed terrible response back to someone
like a go hope you look I hope you die
right like you know gonna get it right
then here was another 1i got a lot of
these this was just [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you know that's pretty
standard Nevada here have anything you
want to add into that this one if you
[ __ ] care about women you will find a
lot in other countries who needs all
kinds of help [ __ ] you mouth you piece
of [ __ ] all right let's forget the
smelling thing there but but this is my
point about being a liberal y'understand
for liberal principles yes women have
problems in all kinds of places I think
we should stand up for all of them this
is just one example is ok so let's say
that this person who wrote that there's
women who need help in all sorts of
countries go help them well then who's
to say the people in those other
countries you want us to help wouldn't
say the same thing they'd go oh no you
go back to Saudi Arabia and help them
right so just the logic there is stupid
just because you don't want help in your
own country and you want to send them
off that that would mean don't help
anybody in any countries what she's
saying cuz if it's not welcome you
wouldn't help like that's just the first
thing the second thing is if would help
everybody if you want to be helped right
you want to be helpful I would like
women to be equal I know it's radical
and crazy here's another one first who
are you that's a good question who the
hell am I that's a good idea second shut
up your mouth because you don't know
anything that's a very existential reply
no I know that one for like three hours
I was like who am I had a weapon it got
in your head uh here's a good one
put your opinion in your ass he's a
great king so again so a lot of these
were from people inside are any but now
again apparently he did do a lot with
education and they you know he reformed
some things but I wasn't talking about
any I was just giving you three basic
yes adding making a common that that is
what makes you a moderate in the Middle
East which is actually true right that's
so true as well so that's like the
ultimate irony right like somebody who
is doing these things women cannot drive
he was okay with that and he's
considered a moderate right I feel like
the ghost of him is like I was a
moderate and fair king by the standards
of the middle he's sitting up there
right now like I was a moderate in fair
game I know it's made me Jeanie I'm
sorry that was probably that no I should
be getting a phobic I mean how terrible
I am because I just Jeanne to the king
yeah sorry um here's another interesting
one just [ __ ] you [ __ ] simple pretty
good right to the point ok got it IE
beheading of people in the gays you know
not know with that and here was an
interesting one women are super happy in
Saudi we are drivers for them they do
not have to drive why do you care about
women in Saudi [ __ ] so women are so happy
and treated so well in Saudi Arabia that
men are their chauffeurs and then I
forget the fact that me and he just
totally negated anything he says by just
randomly throwing in the [ __ ] I'm like
that's not even to your point you can
look at your point about how women
really like not having freedom because
you've decided to do everything for us
that's like a classic like abusive
husband type thing like O'Neal classic
almost like American abuse would be like
you can't go to work and I'm providing
for you but you like it cuz I'm taking
care of you meanwhile the woman's like
scared and like hiding under the bed
teeth chattering this person this guy
has decided that all women in Saudi
Arabia or woman all Saudi women are
happy because their freedoms are taken
away but the men have decided to take
care of what you watch I know there's
nothing that'll piss a woman off more
than allowing her to drive well joining
sucks if you want to get me a driver
that's fine so anyway there were a whole
bunch more it's not worth getting it's
not worth going through all them but I
just thought it was interesting because
I feel this is going on constantly with
liberals there's this weird thing of
like we have to stand up for our
principles which is what I try to talk
about and try to do and free speech and
we could talk about the Paris thing and
all that and yet we don't I'm not saying
we should bomb these people I'm gonna
think I should do anything but we but we
should be allowed to talk about it lets
people conversation is scary this
conversation leads to critical thinking
when you get too many people critically
thinking about things that's when change
can occur and a lot of people are really
scared of change so of course the first
thing they want to do is shut down even
having speech about it or thoughts about
it that's what people are so angry shut
the [ __ ] up instead of being like you
know I don't necessarily agree that's
what you're getting such a strong
respond yeah and by the way I'm all for
these people cursing me off telling me
to go [ __ ] myself and all these things i
think it's great but i think this what's
the sad part is that they can't do that
to their own government or they'd be
killed or beheaded or put in jail or
whatever so i get it like they're
actually it's sort of the double-edged
sword of this thing it's like they
weirdly have to attack people who are
actually trying to help them it's like
right just born of frustration maybe the
whole yeah that's like this is gonna be
like sound like such a terrible
comparison have you ever been in a store
or a situation where someone's not
empowered to help you like a bank teller
or somebody in a store I'm serious right
I don't get really frustrated in there
and you go God like I hate working with
people the DMV or I hate dealing with
bank tellers anybody we traditionally
hate dealing with usually as somebody
who's had power taken away from them in
their position so I feel like you can
look on a larger scale that the people
of countries that don't have a lot of
freedom and don't have a lot of power or
dealing with that same frustration that
just makes them automatically kind of
angrier and just how they're not living
a happy full life so of course you're
gonna react like in a snappy quick right
and I empathize with them I actually
feel bad for him so that's why I wasn't
I'm not even doing this to mock these
people really in any way as much as I
just think it's really interesting and
particularly for liberals I think it is
it's really interesting what do you
think you want to tell me to go [ __ ]
myself let us some of the comments wreck
envelope